où sont passés les macros du golfe du
Saint-Laurent autrefois abondant les
stocks de ce poisson s'effondre au point
où on a dû interdire la pêche
commerciale au printemps dernier le même
jour on a aussi interdit la pêche au
harengs un coup dur pour les pêcheurs
mais une décision inévitable selon les
chercheurs
[Musique]
au grand plaisir des adeptes de pêche le
maquereau est au rendez-vous à
Sainte-Anne-des-Monts en Gaspésie comme
chaque été
pourtant le stock est jugé critique
depuis plus de 10 ans en 2021 le
ministère pêche chez océan Canada a pour
la première fois fixer une limite de
prise même pour la pêche récréative
car on a droit à un macro par personne
il faut qu'on respecte une longueur du
poisson aussi
prétexte de pêche récréative certains
pêcheurs en profiter pour amener plus de
200 kg de macro à pied sans obligation
de déclarer ses prises avec cette
nouvelle réglementation le ministère
espère diminuer la pression sur la
ressource
[Musique]
pour Camille gagné pêcher le maquereau
c'est un métier elle est capitaine
depuis trois ans
ici au Québec les pêcheurs de maquereau
c'est souvent des plus petits pêcheurs
puis on est tous un interdépendant nous
notre macro il sert à fournir un appât
pour les pêcheurs commerciaux de crabe
et de mort environ 90% des macro péchés
au Canada se retrouvent dans une cage
pour l'appât des pêches les plus
lucratives du pays le reste est destiné
à la consommation humaine
[Musique]
seulement voilà le stock de macro du
nord-ouest de l'Atlantique a aujourd'hui
atteint son plus bas niveau historique
on avait des abondances assez élevés au
début des années 2000 et puis à peu près
à partir de 2010 on est en décroissant
la pêche continuer tout ça mais on n'a
pas d'arriver de nouvelles coord dans le
stock dans qu'au fil du temps mais on
est passé d'un stock qui était très
abondant un stock qui aujourd'hui n'est
à peu près qu'à 10% de son abondance
normale on va dire les causes du déclin
sont multiples c'est en partie la
surpêche en partie une abondance de
prédateurs qui est présentement très
élevé dans le système les prédateurs
naturels foggs gris par exemple le thon
rouge qui est un recrudescence les
oiseaux marins comme le foot bassin et
puis aussi bien faible recrutement donc
une faible survie des jeunes stades de
vie après l'éclosion des œufs
comme je l'ai déjà mentionné le stock de
macro est dans un état très critique
depuis déjà 10 ans et le temps est venu
de leur donner une chance de rétablir
pour contrer la surexploitation du
maquereau cette année la ministre
fédérale des pêches joyce Meyer a
interdit la pêche commerciale partout en
Atlantique et au Québec à 48 heures du
début de la saison c'est la première
interdiction visant cette espèce dans
l'histoire des pêches canadiennes
depuis plusieurs années on a mis en
place plusieurs mesures pour essayer
d'arrêter la diminution du stock mais
malheureusement ça n'a pas à arrêter les
diminutions et c'est pour cette raison
qu'on a arrêté le pêche commercial et
aussi la pêche de la part à cette année
[Musique]
les pêcheurs entendaient parler de
diminution du stock mais pas au point
nécessité une fermeture de la pêche on
s'y attendait pas du tout puis
clairement cette année malheureusement
ça va être un année déficitaire pour la
convaincre
jamais investi près de 70 000 dollars
juste pour la pêche au maquereau j'ai
utilisé mon équipement 3 mois puis cette
année malheureusement
dans mon portefeuille de permis moi j'ai
du crabe des neiges j'ai Haren macro et
Bourgault c'est pas des permis qui
pourraient compenser au prix du fioul et
de la pop présentement le Burgo c'était
même pas envisageable de mettre une cage
à l'eau
[Musique]
cette interdiction touche des centaines
de pêcheurs et de transformateurs au
pays comme L'Oréal lièvre pêcheur
professionnel depuis plus de 45 ans
mon plan c'était de finir ma carrière là
dedans tout tranquillement
sans stress
j'ai vendu mon petit coteau de crabe au
printemps ça s'est faite dans la même
journée fermeture de la pêche au macro à
11h30 et j'ai signé mon dernier souffle
au crabe à deux heures trente
l'après-midi avec ça
[Musique]
un hameçon un poisson
une méthode de pêche efficace et durable
selon ce capitaine passionné
[Musique]
mais aujourd'hui la pêche sera de courte
durée parce qu'elle est scientifique
grâce aux pécheurs le ministère pêché
océan Canada collecte des données entre
autres sur l'âge la taille et la période
de ponte des macros présentement j'ai le
droit à 300 kg par sorti par semaine ça
fait que les autres ils remontent le
poisson il mesure il congèle
ouvert ou pas on sait rien
pour couvrir toutes les eaux de l'Est
canadien le ministère compte 12 pêcheurs
partenaires pour la pêche scientifique
ce qui semble bien peu pour Ghislain
Colin du regroupement des pêcheurs
pélagiques du Sud de la Gaspésie ça
prendrait des pages sentinelles
justement à cette île abcomo sur le côté
nord de la Gaspésie le poisson est là
le maquereau est un poisson migrateur
qui se déplace en banc des États-Unis
jusqu'à Terre-Neuve de juin à septembre
quand on le pêche on envoie par milliers
ce qui peut donner une impression
d'abondance
en plus des pêches scientifiques le
ministère évalue le stock de macro grâce
au relevé annuel des œufs
l'abondance des œufs est proportionnelle
à l'abondance des femelles donc si on
fait ensuite x 2 ça nous donne une idée
très fiable de
l'abondance du maquereau qui arrive dans
le golf du Saint-Laurent pour se
reproduire on juge que le relevé des
œufs de macro est relativement robuste
parce qu'effectivement on observe
souvent des macros à l'extérieur du Sud
du golf du Saint-Laurent ce qui peut
nous montrer qu'il y a de la
reproduction qui se déroule aussi
ailleurs que dans le sud du golfe quand
ces observations là sont faites pêche au
sein Canada étant son relevé à ces zones
là mais jusqu'à maintenant ça a toujours
été une fraction infime qui fait que
c'est négligeable dans les calculs de la
biomasse du maquereau donc pour
l'instant on est confiant que malgré le
réchauffement climatique le maquereau
pond toujours dans le sud du golf du
Saint-Laurent
les phoques viennent après nous autres
mais aussi
certains pêcheurs contestent la gestion
de la pêche au macro du ministère pêche
et océan Canada qu'ils estiment
nuisibles pour la protection de la
ressource
on est autorisé nous pêcheurs québécois
professionnels
ils doivent partager le quota avec de
bien plus gros bateaux de Terre-Neuve
qui eux pêchent à la scène une sorte de
grand filet circulaire flottant le
Seigneur ramasse ça à coup de 300 tonnes
par nuit 300 tonnes par nuit c'est 3 ans
de mes péchés
que ça sorte voyons donc
si tu n'imaginable
il y a quelqu'un qui devrait dire bon
ben c'est
c'est un gros bateau tu vas avoir du
poisson tu as le droit 500
[Musique]
autre point de discorde la déclaration
des prises malgré une gestion fédérale
des pêches les règles varient d'une
province à l'autre au Québec et à
Terre-Neuve par exemple les pêcheurs
remplissent un journal de bord et
déclare leur prise avant de rentrer au
quai mais ce n'est pas vrai pour l'Île
du Prince des doigts et une partie du
Nouveau-Brunswick
S qui ont dans leur usine mais le
pêcheur qui débarque OK puis emmène son
poisson chez eux
il est à lui
pourquoi qui ont pas mis ça en place
pour toutes les autres pêcheurs
justement s'il y avait tant besoin de ça
de donner scientifique c'était
primordial qui l'intègre des autres
pages
cette année après mon expérience j'ai
perdu une saison de 200000 livres ces
200000 pièces mais ce qui est déplorable
c'est qu'ils ont fermé après mais ils
veulent pas nous aider on a aucune aide
gouvernemental alors qu'on se parle
[Musique]
les conséquences se font aussi sentir
sur certains crabiers et omardiers qui
ont dû faire venir gros prix leurs
appâts de l'étranger d'Espagne d'Islande
ou encore des États-Unis un pays avec
lequel le Canada partage pourtant le
même stock de macro qui était d'ailleurs
géré conjointement jusqu'en 2011
c'est sûr qu'il faut encore regarder
qu'est-ce qui se passe aux États-Unis
pour nous assurer que nos mesures vont
fonctionner vont résulter dans un arrêt
de diminution du stock
est incertain pour le rétablissement de
la population de maquereau et sa pêche
mais cette espèce à la faculté de
rebondir plus facilement que la morue
par exemple donc il reste de l'espoir la
raie d'un an présentement de la page
n'aura pas un effet rapide
il faut être patient il faut que
attendre finalement qu'on a des bonnes
cohortes il s'agit d'obtenir une bonne
année et puis on pourrait assister à un
rétablissement en trois ou quatre ans à
ce moment-là
[Musique]
donc c'était plutôt spécifique à cette
année et à revoir pour 2023 donc il y a
quand même une lueur d'espoir mais dans
les pêches on sait jamais
[Musique]
si je commencerai une vie je regroupe et
la liberté on a tout sur l'eau
les pêcheurs sont convaincus qu'une
pêche bien contrôlée protégerait la
ressource à long terme alors
[Musique]